the agreement helps pave the way for
president Trump's plan summit with kim
jeong-hoon
major garrett is at the white house with
that part of the story major how is the
president responding to these new
agreements
well gala won't surprise you two tweets
on this subject in the last half-hour
the most recent one starting all caps
Korean War to end
President Trump saying that is great for
the people of America something that
this country should take some pride in
his earlier tweet possibly more
important the president said good things
are happening but only time will tell
that note of caution reflects US desire
to see North Korea follow through on
many of the commitments implied by this
North Korea South Korea summit what how
and when will North Korea denuclearize
will actually reduce troop strength on
the Demilitarized Zone and if it does
will that include dismantling artillery
and ballistic missiles the artillery
threatened South Korea the ballistic
missiles US allies throughout the region
and while the White House awaits answers
to all of these complex questions last
night Sara Sanders a press secretary
released a statement saying the White
House looks forward to quote robust
discussions with the north about that
much anticipated and equally historic
summit if it occurs between President
Trump and Kim jong-un in quote the
coming weeks Nora all right major thank
you for your reporting